hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play minimal theory
okay this is an interesting game that is
made on the Unreal Engine and seems to
have a lot of work but into it was
released rather recently on gamejolt and
uh it's pretty highly reviewed I know
very little about it but um press here
to play alright it's obviously made on
the Unreal Engine hello it uh oh I have
a flashlight would you be so kind as to
pick up a suitcase not a drink while you
read did you say would you kindly like
the tone of your voice whoa what the
hell is a spectrum of pure white what
you say HAP's you were a bit dehydrated
I don't think I want to drink okay
I drank now what what what why I'm
confused already I'm barely in the game
you can't confuse me that soon what is
that the end of the hallway
okay I see a kind of a line on it up I
can't see it it's fuzzy
hello hi is there something here oh look
a door goody goody gumdrops I like this
more soda pop
ray look over the messenger this Judy I
mean easy juice that's totally not made
out of toxic waste ideal for your
hazardous testing needs hazardous
testing well is this worse than crap uh
okay sorry I'm kind of talking over you
I don't mean to what the hell is going
on here what the hell is happening okay
I see it what was that I saw flash of
red boxes boxes I think boxes whoa what
the
they just duplicate is this the room of
multiplying boxes you can click on them
and you can make them dance so lotty day
there's something under here that I need
no no no no no no no
no no no I guess not
okay this is a room full of boxes that
you can toss around I thought for sure
there'd be something hiding here okay
all right
moving on then they're actually rooms on
the walls that I'm not seeing or was
that the only run that was yelling Boom
Boom Bang II I can knock stuff around
how cool is that
ah here's another door another red room
with blocks is boom back ah ah outside
get off of there I saw I can't hide it
for me got it yeah I got a key so what
do I do about that
does that unlock this or hello no yes no
maybe so okay not that door so this key
must unlock another door that's around
here some way does the door looks like a
door open ah okay the key does not
unlock that door key probably unlocks
another door around here I'm still
confused as to what's going on but at
least I have a clue so I'm testing some
sort of something is that what I heard
in there infinite chasm of that narrator
there isn't another door here what am i
doing I can't go back I can't I no no no
I can't
what am I supposed to do was er key in
that room that I missed there might have
been hang on let me try something
and go back in this room
no no they're moving around on their own
I don't like that but not much you can
do about it there might have been
something here that I'm overlooking some
reason the shadows don't work perfectly
my flashlight does not open what did I
just do
i grunted why did i grunt maybe I just
need to spam my use key over find
something no no okay no well now I'm
confused
there's something under these barrels
maybe I have no idea I'm so confused
what am I doing with my life
whoa what happened oh that's me when I
jump I must be really heavy okay oh Sh a
boo shoot fish you all over there we go
I can open it before consumption a Boosh
ha bear ski yellow rum tell me your
secrets explain to me explain to me
what's going on here what's with all
this what's all this then you don't have
a key or are you just holding out on me
I think you're just holding out on me
nope nope no key damn it what was the
point of coming in this room maybe maybe
I maybe it's like that door over there
and I need to just be really
enthusiastic about trying to open this
damn there we go why did that take 10
million tries Oh No okay
there we go
on the table things your left whatever
you do don't open it I want to open it I
really really want to open it now
congratulations subject 8-0 in three are
you successfully graduated from testing
Academy yay
alright everybody thank you so much for
believing me I'm gonna open the suitcase
come on gonna get it closed whoa where
am i this doesn't look like graduation
ah oh god I I didn't mean to I'm sorry
this is like portal isn't it trying to
burn me alive where's that just a big
joke thank you thank you for not killing
not supposed to kill you
thanks for being honest honesty is
always the best policy I've found
precedent but you really don't want to
see what's on the other side I think I
do
what's on the other side yeah I'm gonna
find out your rap aah no no aah
oh no I'm gonna drown no wait no I'm not
that's a lie you're just a stupid
narrator and I'm a super smart human
you're probably some computer every
knows computers are dumb the human big
smart big brain wrangle smash you smash
you in your computer face how is that
you how has my flawless puzzle of deal
open the pod bay doors Hal did I get it
and I solve your puzzle well well it
appears you made it all this way for
nothing yeah you should just turn back
hello no don't leave I just get lonely
and like that fun mmm
yes you're fun involve murder I mean we
all have our hobbies but maybe you
should pick another one bye-bye
okay all right still loading loading
something big loading something so big
for me how about fire up the super
awesome mega simulator because they
think I'm in a computer program if I'm
not mistaken well I mean or it's at
toxic waste that I drank gallons of
before that are suddenly degrading my
mind my simple primitive human brain me
big smart you big dumb that's what you
be you big dumb you super big dumb and
this loading is taking forever what's
the deal and I'll be back once it starts
there stops loading would you be so kind
as to pick up a suitcase have a drink
while you're ready what oh what the
hell's going on what I can hear myself
moving around in there but that sounded
like the beginning of the game okay so
what I guess that's it did I break the
game
where are my coming hahaha I'm just
navigating okay nevermind okay so I
guess that's the end of the game I guess
hahaha
hope you're enjoying this awesome
loading screen that's stuck here forever
that was an interesting game not what I
was expecting very different from what I
had anticipated not too bad either and
it for free game it's not bad so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation more videos it I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
mm what all that
due to my left
water
I see what
god I see what
you're going far
haha